there's also something so kind of like
pure about the elements of intimacy in
this one they're doing things for the
very first time they're just very very
like animalistic Kristen Stewart Dan
Nicholas holds experienced forbidden
romance and first love in equals out to
July 15th we kind of watched them fall
in love for the first time and there's
something so beautiful and romantic
about that did you guys pull from the
first time that you were both in love to
get into that headspace yeah definitely
I read the script and I was like god
this is just gonna suck not gonna hurt
him just like place yourself in that
feeling you know that maybe you've had
before it's it's like the most visceral
intense overwhelming feeling and so when
it's really great it's epically great
and when it's bad it's epically bad we
knew going into it that it would be like
oh this is gonna be like this is gonna
hurt him I know the first time we fall
in love you're sentimental that it's
very difficult to recall anything isn't
Mia kind of reminded me a little bit of
Bella in Twilight and that's because you
see how much she's willing to give up
for love in the end she's willing to
change your whole her whole life do you
think that that's a strength or or a
weakness
are you laughing um yeah I'm obviously
really drawn to that idea that element
of both stories is really what kind of
turns me on the most about them you're
emotionally or like wrought you're
completely raw you're willing to give it
all up for someone but really you're
finding yourself in doing that you're
like it's bold to do that it's
courageous to give yourself to someone
like that so yeah I took that idea
seriously
if we stay here we'll be found out if
you make this decision there's no
turning back